non attendez soyons soyons clairs vous
êtes arrivés vous êtes au téléphone vous
avez pas de ceinture vous avez pas de
soutien-gorge qu'est-ce qu'on fait nous
on vous arrête
[Musique]
test test
pour la fête de la musique
c'est vachement agréable bonjour
la fête de la musique on fait des essais
pardon
pas très fort
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon c'est bon
merci Tony
tu es trop fort
petite mesure là juste un petit contrôle
de routine
parce qu'il y a une péniche qui a lâché
une caisse là
vous faites toute la rue comme ça
non
non ça se sent pas les radiations
de toute façon moi je dois partir alors
maintenant vous allez
comme je sais pas si on va pas mettre le
périmètre en quarantaine
pas pouvoir vous laisser sortir ça
et la moyenne c'est combien
6 6 6
je suis arménien c'est pour ça
d'aller prendre une douche non
[Rires]
un bain de bouche un lavement un suppo
et Oli tu parles en dessous de la foot
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ici là on prend des mesures des
mesures de quoi attendez
cette mesure
parce que j'ai mon petit cousin qui
passe le bac là je lui ai prêté un Toky
là pour l'aider un petit coup ça vous
fait rire
et en trigonométrie mais c'est quoi là
c'est parce qu'il a des épreuves il est
en train de passer là j'ai un petit
micro émetteur et là j'ai une oreillette
et j'entends tout ce qu'il me dit et ça
c'est de la magouille qui de la poule ou
de l'oeuf est arrivé en premier
philosophe
puisque l'œuf ne vit que si la poule est
là
c'est la logique
mais elle est arrivée comment la poule
parce que oui c'est l'œuf
alors il faudrait je sais pas comment
tourner ça par contre
[Musique]
oh là là
bonjour monsieur
vous connaissez en philo un petit peu
qui de la poule de la ceinture déjà
qui de la poule ou de l'œuf est arrivé
en premier
très franchement je sais pas monsieur
je vais être obligé de vous compter la
ceinture alors il faut qu'il explique
que c'est par la poule et qu'évidemment
la poule est arrivée également par
l'oeuvre donc ben non c'est execo c'est
le Big Bang ah le Big Bang quand il y a
eu le big bang pour il y a une poule
directement c'est vrai
et après il y en a juste une petite
après c'est à partir de combien est-ce
de trop
je l'ai su en plus
un train à part d'un point B à 16h30 il
met 45 minutes pour arriver à quelle
heure il arrivera donc si je réponds je
vais avoir une deuxième contravention
parce que la première je vais la voir là
tu t'y connais en lettres toi ouais
voyelle
oh
consonne
BP consonne
CC et voyelles
eux
puisque ceux que je foute avec ça
pas mieux
bonjour monsieur contrôle de pastille
la pastille de quoi
être méchant avec moi je viens de me
faire des panason
ouvert tout mon courrier je suis
d'accord avec eux je peux pas la mettre
sur le pare-brise parce que je l'ai pas
reçu
qui la donne qui la donne recevoir
et vous avez le reçu ou pas vous avez
pas la pastille verte vous avez pas la
peine
vous êtes père ou le contraire donc
à savoir
mais je suis content c'est un stylo s'il
vous plaît
rendez-vous à ma place ou quoi là genre
tout de suite la pastille la voiture la
moins d'un an du genre il faut une
passible sur la voiture et que si elle
est dans la minute qu'on nous demande ça
et vous êtes tous les deux là comme ça
tous les deux vous allez bloquer la
voiture vous croyez quoi moi franchement
je m'arrache non non non attendez
monsieur
et justement vous faites un peu vite je
m'arrache hein oh non vous n'avez pas me
faire un PV mais la dame elle a un
chewing-gum ça marche pas il est vert en
plus ouais il est vert non voilà
je vais la chercher tout de suite
[Musique]
quand il pleut c'est un père et quand il
fait beau c'est super voilà c'est bon
vous pouvez y aller alors c'est bon
mais n'oubliez pas de la coller la
prochaine fois
vous prenez un petit peu de peinture
chez vous vous faites un petit rond vert
ça le fait
[Applaudissements]
pour la ceinture non j'ai pas mis
clignotants pour passer sur
l'appareil et vous viendrez le récupérer
ce soir au commissariat vous allez me
donner votre téléphone parce qu'on l'a
rectifié ce soir
[Applaudissements]
je viens de l'avoir depuis hier nous on
confisque les téléphones
je suis désolé
téléphone bah non c'est pas pleurer
c'est que c'est la catastrophe pour moi
pour le récupérer ce soir à Melun à
Melun et sinon oui et sinon dans 15
jours parce que là il y a le pont
moi je peux pas la menaces
et mon copain aussi il faut lui donner
effectivement sensibiliser à
l'interdiction etc
d'être effectivement situation de non
circulation avec moi mon engin et si
problème de m'arrêter et de me garer et
de faire mes petites affaires je
comprends rien j'ai décroché
merci Monsieur
bonne journée
soyons clairs vous êtes arrivés vous
êtes au téléphone vous avez pas de
ceinture vous avez pas de shooting gorge
qu'est-ce qu'on fait nous on vous arrête
mais qu'est-ce je voulais que je fasse
soutien-gorge ça me regarde j'ai la
poitrine qui tient heureusement je suis
jeune
pas de passer du tout là pour la
collecte pour la Croix-Rouge
[Musique]
il faut donner aux
lui donne pas
un petit truc la soupe c'est bien ouais
c'est à quel parfum
parce que légumes
tire-bouchon pour les bouteilles ah non
ça va pas le faire alors pour donner ça
et puis un mot je vous fais un mot pour
votre patron on a besoin de plein de
trucs
j'ai vraiment besoin de
toi
j'ai le truc au bureau pour pas nous en
donner un
ou deux
vous voyez hein
c'est pour une bonne cause
pour moi c'est pas pour vous ça c'est
pas cette couleur mais je prends passe
par fin il nous faut du savon du
shampoings et serviettes la teinture
pour cheveux enfin plein de trucs
donc c'est pas vous dire les données pas
une liste précise non pas une liste
précise d'accord merci Madame en plus
foncez peut-être la teinture alors
attendez
[Musique]
ça va pas vous manquer je vous en donne
quand même parce qu'on sait jamais si
vous êtes pas en panne d'accord très
bien
et puis les fleurs pour ma femme
[Musique]
partout
qui est de votre côté quoi puisque c'est
à Lui bon alors
vous touchez pas
[Musique]
vous descendez pas là c'est tout ce que
vous lui piquez toutes les prunes
qui dit
mon boulot monsieur
je suis en train de manger je vous dis
de ne pas ne pas intervenir vous êtes
chez moi alors je sais pas moi qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce que c'est que ce machin
chez moi je veux pas vous n'avez pas
vous avez le droit de rentrer chez moi
bien sûr non allez voir le gars allez le
voir vous moi je sais pas mon voisin
vous êtes chez moi si je et vous vous me
jetez monsieur j'ai pas de jardin moi
j'ai pas dit mais moi je vous dis vous
n'intervenez pas chez moi et qu'est-ce
que c'est que cette histoire mais je
sais ça débarque comme ça là ça débarque
je sais pas c'est quoi le problème avec
votre voisin moi je sais pas moi je n'ai
pas de problème avec mon voisin aller
voir le voisin pas de contrôle moi c'est
pas moi faute à moi si vous êtes en
bises avec le voisin
votre démarche
merde alors
comment on fait pour la facture parce
que la facture est à votre frère
vous voulez vous faire chier comme le
longtemps pardon je vais prendre une
trique à la fin là une mais qu'est-ce
que vous me racontez de facture là
maintenant voilà allez allez vous pouvez
me prendre en photo là avec s'il vous
plaît
merci attention
oh merde merde le truc n'est pas cassé
c'est déboîté ça c'est pas des boîtes
pour moi ça c'est mort pour moi vous
m'avez cassé mon bras appareil photo je
l'avais pas encore dans la main
j'ai tout le temps
qu'est-ce que tu fais
malheureusement mais c'est pas un
jetable
oh merde
je crois que vous l'aviez
oublié
en plus je vous insulte pas j'étais
courtois j'ai rien dit tu me casses mon
appareil en plus
d'accord vas-y vas-y
voilà voilà alors voilà on fait un
constat maintenant
réflex quelle maladroit vous faites
quand même je fais
oh merde
ouais vous êtes doué vous êtes gardien
de but
bien essayé quand même oh là là le sac
regardez vous mangez comme un porc aussi
c'est bon pour les cheveux c'est pas
grave c'est pas grave
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors
quand même oui peut-être
un petit garçon
moi je veux bien oui tu viens avec moi
je le fais à 8000
ce matin mais les gens s'accrochent pas
quoi mais il est tout option il est
mignon
j'ai pas d'argent je suis au bout du
rouleau
vous préférez qu'il soit dans la rue
avec moi
je peux pas vendre ma voiture et je m'en
sers dans ma voiture vous le vendez et
il fait bien dans sa caisse au lieu
d'aller des boîtes à manger et il évite
son assiette
si ça vous arrange pas vous faites de
chèques le deuxième je le mets à la fin
du mois
à une question alors encore une question
elle c'est gratuit pourquoi vous vendez
parce que vous avez vous avez des
problèmes d'argent j'ai joué au casino
j'ai tout perdu sur le 8 et il faut que
je rembourse parce que j'avais fait un
prêt et puis il rigole pas là-bas
et la mer la mer elle est pas au courant
je veux pas qu'elle le sache je vais lui
dire que je l'ai perdu on fera vite
recherche s'il retrouve pas bon voilà
quoi
on ira aux objets trouvés et puis
si c'est sérieux déjà
ça s'achète pas même si j'avais les
moyens
j'ai les papiers j'ai tout avec
vous avez plus qu'à signer à faire le
chèque moi c'est une chose vous en avez
une autre mais il y a l'enfant aussi il
faut demander son avis aussi
[Musique]